when you're making a hundred million
dollars a year
to play sports
your life changes
there are certain rules and regulations
you have to live by plain and simple you
can't do stupid stuff that's the
trade-off now if you want to do all that
stuff and give all that money back more
power to you you can make that stance
you know what I want to do what I want
to do
I want to flash my gun and make videos
and do things okay that's fine but you
can't make money on the NBA doing this
stuff first of all you're not a thug
you're not a criminal you're not a crook
you're a guy making a hundred million
dollars a year to dribble is 200 200
million to dribble a stupid basketball
[Music]
you got to look into me and say yeah you
know what maybe I'm the problem